Bộ giáo dục và đạo cho biết đã mang hành thông tư số mề chính, hàng in thông chạm hai miso, trở đầu.
Bộ suốt mồ sư điều của quy định về rận thêm học thêm, những dựa đổi được xe dất dựa trên những có ý dành giả tắt nợ.
Phản hồi được thực tiến của điều puy hơn, giáo viên của quyền và giáo hội.
Không tư có hiệu lực thí hành từ ngày May 15, năm 2020, hàng in thông chạm hai miso.
Không tư mới, tiếp tục không cấm rận thêm, học thêm chỉ nán.
Không hạn chế nút cầu học tập tập pháp của người học và quyền rận hợp của giáo viên.
Bộ tiêu chọng tâm của thông tư là sức trạm kỳ cương, ngăn chạm dự thêm trải phép, app quốc quốc sục lợi.
Bảo vệ mối triển giáo dục lên May, công bằng trong tiếp cận giáo dục với mọi lối tựa liên quan,
không tư mới, quốc quy định, các hoạt lực giáo dục về bán hòa, gẹt thuật, thế thao,
khăn cường năng nực ngoại ngữ giáo dục năng lực số, chỉ trởi như tạo AI, giáo dục cứ nghiệp, giáo dục cứ năng sống,
và các nội dung giáo dục khác theo quy định, nhằm giáo dục quan giết đáp ứng nhu cầu, sở thích, năng hiểu của học sinh.
Má không thuộc nội dung trương trình, gán môn học, giáo bộ trưởng bộ giáo dục và đặc bán hành.
Thì không thuộc phản video chính của thông tư này và được thực hiện theo các quy định khác của pháp lợi.